hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 14
video only two episodes left I would say
you know I've never been more excited to
see a character die after the end of
this episode than I am right now I am so
happy to see a very certain character
die of course you know what that means
that means that he's probably gonna live
longer than anyone else
whenever characters get too sympathetic
that's when they kill him if any of you
guys were live tweeting with me on
Twitter you saw I actually like some of
the really big WTF moments I had gifs of
like right after they happened but
because they're so spoilery I couldn't
post any of them they're just burning a
hole in my harddrive right now with that
in mind let's just get to it just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet there are so
many WTF deaths that we have to talk
about starting with top 5 WTF moments
number 5
Glen Eden in the EDM truck did anyone
else think that the music playing was a
little on the nose I loved that Eugene
was able to use it later in the episode
to distract the walkers but still like
why why would you play really loud music
while you were driving around in the
apocalypse unless you were doing what
Eugene did in trying to attract walkers
as the audience we've spent all of our
time with the survivors so we know how
bad it is so the people at Alexandria
seemed really dumb but I guess if you've
been living in Alexandria this whole
time you wouldn't be thinking like the
survivors Aidan totally thought he was
hardcore
Glenn pulled the rug out from under him
and even though it seemed like they were
on good terms whenever they went on that
mission it still wasn't enough to keep
Aidan from just charging headfirst into
getting them all blown up I'll be
interested to see if the truck or the
EDM gets used as a weapon in the in the
finale
on to number 4 Carol and Sam cookies
round 2 it started out really funny and
they just went to [ __ ] by the end of
their scenes I felt so bad for Sam by
the end you you could definitely tell
like towards the end their conversation
the direction that it was going there
aren't any visible bruises on Sam but
that doesn't mean the Pete's not abusing
him too and all of a sudden you see the
wheels turn in Carol's head and she
knows exactly what has to happen if
you've read the comic books this is
straight out of the comics like this
sequence of events I mean the way
they're doing it is different because
Carol wasn't around at this time she'd
already died by the time they got to
Alexandria in the comics it makes sense
that they would tie her story to this
abuse story just because she was abused
by Edie
also if you remember when Carol and
Daryl went into Atlanta they took that
book the abuse book but Carol said that
she and her child stayed in that
building when they were away from Edie
he'd been abusing her so she needed to
get away onto number three she goes down
in the warehouse there were so many
great death scenes in this episode
mostly associated with their warehouse
storyline first we have Aidan just
getting getting his guts shredded
that was another [ __ ] that I couldn't
post I was like this is so good I just I
can't post it too spoilery
he manned up at the end it was kind of
hard to tell the confession that he was
making me Glen I think he was confessing
to leaving the friend behind that that
Walker had killed the one they strung up
and his friend too you could just tell
later in the episode whenever they were
in that sticky situation in the
revolving door yeah he's definitely
gonna be on them too it's like all these
people at Alexandria are total cowards I
wasn't super attached to the Noah
character but I did really like his
death scene just seeing the horror on
Glenn's face he could certainly a little
sympathetic so you know his days were
marked and that thing he wrote in the
journal this is the beginning during
talking dead Tyler James Williams said
that that had a double meaning one it
you know implied everything that Noah
was looking forward to this is the
beginning of a new life here but after
his death it turned into this really
dark thing like this is the beginning of
the [ __ ] hitting the fan
so like the two different storylines no
you had like the stuff that was going on
inside Alexandria and the stuff on this
warehouse run I feel like the warehouse
stuff which is way more poetic although
we'll see when we get to the Pete
Carroll Rick stuff that's an interesting
thought like most poetic death of the
season it was totally infuriating just
all this incompetence but it was really
cool to see Eugene man up finally I knew
that was gonna happen
I just I didn't know when the minute he
and Tara had that conversation are you
really such a coward I told you I'm a
coward and Terry gets put in a situation
where she needs to be rescued obviously
Eugene was gonna man up and rescue her
turns out all he needed was just a truck
full of EDM courage here's a good
question for you guys if Glenn hadn't
come along and knocked you know Aidan's
friend out do you think that Eugene
would have been able to overpower him I
felt like his friend they probably would
have gotten away with the truck but
Eugene still would have stayed this
episode was definitely a big win for
Eugene he is a coward but he's just like
slightly less of a coward after this
episode especially mother dick Abraham
he kind of had a Eugene moment to only
only he's obviously very
much not a coward he's like hell no I
ain't leaving anybody on to number two
Carol tells Rick that he's going to have
to kill Pete it can go down no other way
as much as I'm happy is they're doing so
much comic-book stuff I would really
like to see Carol be the one to kill
Pete just slit his throat and then stuff
a cookie in his mouth as of right now we
don't know a whole lot about Pete all we
know is that he's a doctor and he's a
huge porch dick because there's only two
episodes left I feel like we're just
gonna we're gonna fast-forward through
his storyline I feel like we're not
gonna take a deep dive into Pete anytime
soon unless it's at the end of a knife
it's always interesting to see the way
shows tackle ideas like abuse spousal
abuse child abuse the walking dead very
clearly taking the grim approach it's
like the easiest way to get killed on
the show is to one either be super
hopeful and then like express your hopes
and dreams or to be a child abuser or
you know cite option 3 be a horse and
finally my number one WTF moment
probably the biggest WTF we've had in a
while Gabriel rats out the group to
Deanna as many opportunities as the show
gives you to get upset about something
like really upset I was physically upset
in the middle of Gabriel's confession
I've never been so excited to see
someone die I don't I don't know that
he's gonna die I'd be really upset if he
if he makes it to season six and
sometimes the porch ticks and the
cowards are the ones that survive the
longest that being said I don't think
the show is gonna troll us too much
regardless of when he dies I do think
that it's gonna be in an epoch payoff
like it'll be so rewarding for the
audience you'll just see Twitter explode
and joy I did see some of you guys
joking on Twitter that there's no way
that that staircase would not be
creaking with Maggie like listening in
the conversation they didn't include any
clips from next week's episode of the
group discussing what Gabriel said but
at some point Maggie's gonna have to
rush off to tell Rick like look Gabriel
just ratted us out things are gonna be
really bad and they don't know anything
about the people that died on the
warehouse run I did really like Deanna's
reaction she's like whoa okay clearly
you are super crazy they told us that
they did terrible things so I get it
we're in the apocalypse you have to be
terrible to survive Gabriel's rant was
just so good I would say that's probably
my favorite Gabriel moment it's a bad
moment but it's really fun to watch him
go off the rails like that it's so funny
to watch them
this show and then watch him on the wire
like his character on the wire is just
so much more badass that's really good
jumping-off point so here's my big
question for you guys how do you want
Gabriel to die and do you think that
he's gonna die in the finale or do you
think that he's gonna slink his way into
season six I guess I'm really hoping
that someone impales him with a cross or
like I'd like a church spire falls off
the roof and impales him something with
a lot of Bible imagery a very biblical
death I feel like that would be
appropriate for Gabriel just in terms of
comic book territory for those of you
guys that are that are reading along
we're still in life among them territory
it's this Rick peak conflict that serves
is the impetus that throws us into like
the next big arc they do have synopsis
for the last two episodes out or at
least next week's episode
Darrell find something when he's out
abroad and I think it's gonna have
something to do with the Wolves like
I've said in previous videos I think
that they're like a stand-in for the
scavengers from the comics they're like
the next villainous group the survivors
run into before they get to hilltop
before hilltop appears in the comics I
know everyone really wants to see negan
but I do feel like they're gonna save
him for season six you know hopefully
100th episode is when we'll see a teaser
it's almost time to start making final
predictions about you know like who's
gonna survive to season 6 what's gonna
go down in the finale clearly it's very
self-contained right now it's gonna be
this internal battle this Civil War
inside the safe zone I wouldn't be
surprised if Rick vs. Pete or you know
Carroll versus Pete happens at the very
end of next week's episode leaving the
the finale for like this grand explosion
and this other you know group of
villains to come in it'd be a good way
to lead into season six one coughs which
is over but a new group of villains
comes in and you have to deal with them
in the season premiere next year don't
forget to this fall they're actually at
the end of the summer they're airing the
first six episodes are the only six
episodes of season one of the spinoff so
we're actually getting like six extra
weeks of Walking Dead before season six
premieres Robert Kirkman actually
dropped a bunch of details about the
spin-off so here's what's going on the
show isn't a prequel technically to the
main show it will start a little bit
before like the the timeline where we
are right now in the main show but it
will slowly catch up and run
concurrently so what's happening on the
spin-off will happen at the same time
that stuff is happening on the main show
but there
to be completely separate they're not
gonna be any crossovers it won't have
anything to do with the comics so any
anytime you see a character with like a
similar name to someone else it'll be
completely coincidental they're probably
gonna screen the pilot episode at Comic
Con walking dead always brings a lot of
footage to Comic Con I mean that's why
Robert Kirkman is always good about that
so don't forget new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'm probably gonna
do a double giveaway whenever we get to
the finale video - I'll also I'll start
doing spin-off videos as we start to
learn new stuff but there's still a lot
we don't know about it yet what you guys
wait for the Q&A tomorrow you can click
here to catch up on all my Walking Dead
videos and you can click here for my
latest Game of Thrones Season 5 video
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow now let's all do the
thing